thursday pft live scouting combine
indianapolis the future starts here
here's the future of the nfl this ohio
state football factory is just spitting
out high level pro after high level pro
and this may be the best one yet sorry
nick and joey bosa it's chase young ohio
state edge rusher here with us on set
fresh from the podium chase how are you
buddy i'm good how are you thanks for
having me
so uh man
how
it is amazing how many great ohio state
football players there are right
who's the best guy you've seen during
your time in columbus
other than you
nick boson yeah nick boster uh
dwayne haskins um
it's a lot man you know i could go down
the list terry mclaren
uh shoot
paris campbell jk dobbins
um
and there's one that's coming that
that's that's definitely probably gonna
come out next year ben brown and he's
gonna be uh he'll be a monster how did
it happen that columbus has be and look
i know that's we hear about the sec but
it's like columbus is the center of the
college football universe how did all
these great guys end up in the same
place at the same time um
you know i don't know
to be honest what sold you on going huh
what sold you on going to ohio state uh
i think um it was it was definitely
family oriented um and you know coach
johnson you know his resume the players
that he put in nfl
um you know definitely sold me and uh
you know when i went to friday night
lights and committed uh drills and
things he put me through um talking to
players uh i think that was that what
really sold me i didn't even plan to
commit at that camp but i did offer just
that
who do you
plan to pattern your game after that's
currently in the nfl who's the guy
you're going to try to emulate well a
guy that was in the phil i'd say julius
peppers
i always you know like watching julius
peppers film
you know guys whose bodies are kind of
like mine javon curse um he was a he was
a player who wrecked a lot of havoc too
um so you know i and and and i'm not
really trying to you know pattern my
game around them i want to be the best
chase young i can be but i do like
taking you know little tips and things
um from other people's games as well who
are the other guys other than jewish
peppers where you've studied their film
to find things that you can do to
enhance the chase young pass rushing
portfolio i would say uh the bolster
brothers um
um because you know coming out of oso
state we had all all three of us had the
same toolbox um and as you see in games
uh we we have a lot of similar moves you
know just because we always came from
coach j so um i just see that you know
the toolbox that you know that they
brought from college into the nfl it
works so uh you know i'll definitely be
looking at a at them and you know always
look at nick you know just you know
that's my big bro uh you know see what
he's doing in the league obviously he's
doing outstanding and uh you know i'm
definitely gonna uh you know keep going
how much have you been communicating
with nick as you go through this process
good i talked to him before i got here
talked to him when i got here um all the
only thing he really told me for was
just be be yourself and uh you know
that's that's that's what i've been
trying to do here you've been getting
any pushback from anyone about your
decision not to work out because look i
support it the hayes in the barn go
watch my film i say that all the time
hey i've been playing college football
watch my film if you want to draft me
draft me if you don't one of your
competitors will it's up to you
what what kind of resistance if any of
you gotten you know i
thank you but you know i haven't really
looked at it good or bad you know i just
try to always block the noise out
in regards to anything that i do um but
you know that was a decision that me and
my team came down and chose to make uh
mainly because that that first day of
camp i want to put my best foot forward
and be the best football player that um
i can be
um and you know not waste time trying to
be um a combine player um you know just
be the best football player because you
know that first day camp i'm they're not
going to make around the 40. i'll be
doing drills and and and all types of
football things so you're not doing
anything proud of the draft you're doing
the what are you doing i'm going to i'm
going to do position drills with uh
my coaches but no 40. no 40. that's a
good call and you're right
a wise man once told me there's only two
occasions where a guy runs 40 yards in a
straight line on a football field when
something really good is happening or
when something really bad is happening
right and it doesn't happen any other
time and i bet you've never had to run
40 yards in the straight line other than
to run down the field to chase a
teammate to the end zone yeah if it's so
um i heard you saying over there that
you consider yourself to be the best
player in the draft does it bug you that
it always seems like it's it's got to be
a quarterback who's who's the number one
pick no matter what the other guys can
do no you know that's you know that's
just what it is that's what you know
always has been um but i feel like you
know if you look at my film um from a
defensive standpoint the way i can take
over a game i feel like uh you know in
college football you haven't seen a lot
of people that can tickle again like i
have and um uh i feel like you know my
tape just speaks to me being the best
player in the drive
have you met with the bengals
no no
do you plan to do have you heard from
them or do you i have a formal i believe
are you gonna try to sell them on chase
young over joe burrow i'm gonna try to
sell
myself to every team um but they got the
first pick yeah yeah definitely you know
be the first pick if you make a you sell
them and you watch my film and you know
the i'm safer bet look at what nick bosa
was last year now nothing from kyler
murray but nick bosu was dominant if
they're looking for help on the
defensive line you're the guy i mean
what what how much will you be
especially with a team like the bengals
who has that first pick engaged in that
active process to sell chase young to
them oh i'm selling i'm selling chase
young right now the teams are watching
me on your show um you know
um every team that that i have uh
interviews with i'm just selling chase
young around the board so you know when
that buzz was a round of you know what
type of person he is you know it's not
gonna come from one team it's gonna be a
mixture of every team so i think you
know just being the best person i can be
um you know interviewing interview up
with every team will you know solidify
me as the best player in this draft well
chase we we uh respected admirer how you
going about your business it is a
business decision everybody else makes
business decisions you're allowed to
make business decisions too and we're
glad you're doing it wish all the best
we can't wait to see how things work out
for you chase young ohio state edge
rusher more pft live from the scouting
combine right after
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports